[Musique]
à
mike
parisy
célèbre yes we ou excuses des excuses
des excuses mais ma seule manette seule
marie soleil baril
[Musique]
ap
est ce que vous savez où dorment les
commandants de bord on a la chance de le
voir aujourd'hui puisqu'on avait été
invité par airbus pour mener une
interview regardez ici call cockpit il
ya les commandants qui sont ici et qui
ont leur propre cabine et puisque
personne ne passe à chaque fois cette
porte là je me suis dit que c'était le
moment de vous la contrée
donc là ça ressemble à une lignée chaîne
est en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que pour que les commandants de bord
puisse dormir et se reposer réellement
cette cabine est complètement insonorisé
c'est incroyable on a l'impression
d'être dans un mini bateaux de regarder
ça voilà et là des deux couchettes et je
dors tranquille pendant que mon
homologue conduit juste avant de
reprendre le contrôle de l'avion
l'orangé du marchand
d'émail ami johnny un locatif
et 6 micky six voyous
[Musique]